In this lecture we continue the
discussion of vector space model.
In particular, we're going to talk
about the TF transformation. In the
previous lecture, we have derived a TF
IDF weighting formula using the vector
space model.
And we have shown that this model
actually works pretty well for these
examples, as shown on this slide except
for D5, which has received very high
score.
Indeed, it has received the highest
score among all these documents, but
this document is intuitively non
relevant, so this is not desirable.
In this lecture we're gonna talk about
how we can use TF transformation to
solve this problem.
Before we discuss the details, let's
take a look at the formula for this
simple TF IDF weighting ranking
function and see why this document has
received such a high score.
So this is the formula and if you look
at the formula
carefully, then you will see it
involves a sum over all the matched
query terms.
And inside the sum, each matching query term
has a particular weight and this way it
is TF IDF weighting.
So it has an idea of component where we
see two variables.
One is the total number of documents in
the collection.
And that is M.
The other is the document frequency.
This is the number of documents that
contain this word W.
The other variables involved in the
formula included the count of the
query, term
Term.
W in the query and the count of the
word in the document.
If you look at this document again, now
it's not hard to realize that the
reason why it hasn't received the
highest score is be cause it has a very
high count of campaign.
So the count of campaign in this
document is a four which is much higher
than the other documents and has
contributed to the high score of this
document.
So intuitively, in order to lower the
score for this document, we need to
somehow restrict the contribution of
the matching of this term in the
document.
And if you think about the matching of
terms in a document carefully, you
actually would realize.
We probably shouldn't reward multiple
occurrences.
So generously.
By that I mean the first occurrence of
term says a lot about the matching of
this term because it goes from zero
count to a count of 1 and that
increase
means a lot.
Once we see a word in the document,
it's very likely that the document is
talking about this word.
If we see a extra occurrence on top of
the first occurrence,
that is to go from one to two.
Then we also
can say that was the 2nd occurrence.
Kind of confirmed that it's not a
accidental matching of the word.
Now we are more sure that this document
is talking about this word.
But imagine we have seen, let's say, 50
times of the word in the document.
Then adding one extra occurrence is not
good to tell us more about the evidence
'cause we already sure that this
document is about this word.
So if you think in this way, it seems
that we should restrict the
contribution of high count of term.
And that is the idea of TF
transformation.
So this transformation function is
going to turn the raw count of word
into a term frequency, wait for the
word in the document.
So here I show in X axis the raw count.
In Y axis I showed term frequency
weight.
So in the previous ranking functions we
actually have implicitly used some kind
of transformation.
For example, in the 01 bit vector
representation, we actually use
researcher transformation function as
shown here.
Basically, if the count is 0, then it
has zero weight, otherwise it would
have a weight of 1.
It's a flat.
Now, what about using term count as
TF wait, that's the linear function,
right?
So it has just exactly the same way as
the count.
We have just seen that this is
not desirable.
So what we want is something like this.
So for example, with the logarithm
function, we can have a sub linear
transformation that looks like this and
this would control the influence of
really high weight because it's going
to lower its inference, yet it will
retain the inference of small counts.
Or we might want to even bend the curve
more by applying logarithm twice.
Now people have tried all these methods
and they are indeed working better than
the linear form of the transformation.
But so far what works the best seems to
be this
special transformation called  BM25
transformation. BM stands for best
matching.
Now in this transformation you can see
there's a parameter K here.
And this K controls the upper bound of
this function.
It's easy to see this function has
upper bound.
Because if you look at the x / x + K
where K is non negative number then the
numerator will never be able to exceed
the denominator, right?
So it's upper bounded by K + 1.
This is also difference between this
transformation function and the
logarithm transformation
which doesn't have upper bound.
Furthermore, 1 interesting property of
this function is that as we vary K,
we can actually simulate a different
transformation functions, including the
two extremes that I've shown here.
That is a 01 bit transformation and the
linear transformation.
So for example, if we set K to 0
now you can see,
the function value would be 1.
So we precisely recover
the 01 bit transformation.
If you set K to a very large
number, on the other hand is going to
look more like the linear
transformation function.
So in this sense, this transformation
is very flexible.
It allows us to control the
shape of the transformation.
It also has a nice block of the
upper bound.
And this upper bound is useful to
control the influence of a particular
time.
And so that we can
prevent a spammer from just increasing
the count of one term to spam all
queries that might match this time.
In other words, this upper bound might
also ensure that all terms would be
counted when we aggregate the weights
to computer score.
As I said, this transformation function
has worked well so far.
So to summarize this lecture.
The main point is that we need to do
some linear TV TF transformation, and
this is needed to capture the intuition
of diminishing return from higher term
counts.
It's also to avoid dominance by one
single term over all others. This BM25
transformation that we
talked about
is very interesting.
It's so far one of the best performing
TF transformation formulas.
It has upper bound and social robust
and effective.
If you plug this function into our
TF IDF weighting vector space model.
then we would end up having the
following ranking function which has a
BM 25 TF component.
Now this is
already very close to
2.
a state of the art ranking function
called BM 25.
And will discuss how we can further
improve this formula in the next
lecture.